I'm Wesley for a living I'm a YouTube
videos about battlefield I'm here for
Battlefield Academy now I brought
together poor people who i think you
know probably do with their skills
toning up a little bit they're going to
go into a live stream against the public
on launch day of battle field one
alright guys welcome to battlefield
academy you all know why you're here
you're not very good at battlefield and
you need to get better but first of all
I think we need to establish just how
bad you are okay another guy coming for
the door I got it I killed Elizabeth and
I peep around the corner to see the tank
was following me and it crashed right
through the wall
so the other day when we saw them in
their first match they were sort of
running in as like complete strangers to
the game where pauper spots why we were
stopped and I did say that they were
very good in their own right but they
were missing like a lot of coordination
hi guys they were but still very good
individuals but I think they needed to
work better as a squad for him I have to
hit the guy in the plane and in 72
damnit room so to get them back in the
training room today we're going to give
me some information about the classes
they can play we're going to give them
individual roles and try and get them to
focus during the game and get some
communication Oh in as well we did okay
I came bottom in the scoreboard which is
to be expected i imagined mayhem drama
action it was if it was it was a great
experience if we had some good movements
and good communication and we got the
win which is the main thing I was
running away on a horse and cam had to
throw see from the train as a train was
shooting me and just saved meantime his
grave look an action film but then I did
run in when the tree had like no health
suicided by throwing grenades I died but
I did kill a train so really I'm a
warrior highlight though has to be that
kind of fight at F because I was
grenades going on it was chaotic is
crazy it's everything you come to expect
from battlefield so where she has been
really good although I kind of imagined
him being sterner and maybe a bit more
aggressive and shouting at me but so far
it very nice what are you guys doing I
just hope he does something to be too
harsh on me and so I think he'll be a
bit mean when I make mistakes but he's
quite he looks all nice and kind of like
kind of innocent well if I bet you he'll
be on your back in a second okay so
first round was actually better than I
expected some of you guys were pulling
off some big plays around the F capture
point we had a really really good time
there was pretty hectic for infantry
combat that we all pull together at the
end of the round and I was I was happy
with what I was seeing but I think
there's still a little bit of room for
improvement for all of you and I think
the biggest thing was probably that we
were overlapping on classes and in
battlefield having defined roles for
each different classes really important
and making sure you get those into a
squad so that you can all play together
it's probably the most important thing
because you've all got different tools
that you can use
so spam fish you're going to play
support you've got a big heavy mg that
you can use you're going to be laying
down ammunition you'll be sort of like
the second row of support much pushing
forward they had to throw down some ammo
for us while so you got these guys are
chuck in rounds and grenades at
everybody you're there to provide the
back up when we need throw yes sir I
mean to see what feedback he's got we're
already just watching him and just you
know shadowing almost I'm always learn
more from one game that had from the
last 10 phone books can we're going to
get you to play assault there was a
really good takedown of the train you
sacrificed your life to get rid of the
train during that round was an
impressive move would have been great if
you didn't die but you know overall it
was best it you know you through the
anti-tank grenade in there you did what
you needed to do and you know if if
that's what I saw throughout the round I
think you're probably the best fit to go
for a salt don't go check my kill death
ratio was not good so I'm looking
forward to hearing Wesley's tips just
like survive Brad we're going to get you
to play the medic again you're playing a
similar role to spam fish where you're
going to be providing a lot of support
but this time it's going to be with
health so when you're throwing out all
the health packs that you can and then
using your medic gun your semi-auto
rifle to lay down some good damage at
long range and you can keep people
pushing back rather than them running at
us so make sure you keep that up during
the next round it's nice have a solid
class and understand what they'll do
their disadvantages advantages in our
work together Lenny you're gonna play a
scalp I saw some good action quickly
didn't what's worth coming we're gonna
get you to play a scalp because in the
second part of the round I think you
pulled out then give us the rifleman
loadout yeah weapons and you seem to do
really well with it so the lack of the
scope seem to make it better for you not
really sure why that happened but you
know you pulled up some good moves you
kept spawning in taking down players got
some heavy damage in there and I saw you
throw the flare gun in as get some hits
on the players like I'm up set them on
fire it's all good stuff so we're going
to get you in there as the scalp maybe
you can play a little bit of long-range
as well sitting back with Brad playing
medic and just sort of keeping them back
rather than letting them run at us we
all good let's go for another session I
think I shot about 30 40 shots I am
gonna be the medic
every single one of them already I'm
learning a lot nori I feel like a better
more competent soldier and the worst
thing is is Wesley has made me the Scout
of the team I am now suicide grenade
assault man
right next to it I'm a horse of
slipstream in it with the assault kit
you've got a submachine gun it's the
best thing you can do with those is just
literally hold down the trigger and keep
firing
doesn't need a lot less
let's get effort there so what you could
do here is like if you could get the
spotting flare out and then like it some
three on the keyboard and then just fire
gone yet I've got my flash whoa they're
all on fire over there so if you throw
bandages you just have to tap Q and it
throwback you learning is fun
the confidence levels probably still
lower probably increased my skills by
about three percent I thought he'd be a
bit meaner but he's actually very nice
haha all focus we're all going from one
place and other scenes we've done one
class we know what we're doing next
mainly blowing things up feel great if
you're just running around like a
headless chicken and battlefield you're
just going to die I can't wait to get
into vehicles and ramp it up and get it
into gear and see how far we can go
play it first with EA access